始まりましょうか はい
よろしくお願いします
ちょっと時間空けましたので
1ヶ月間ぐらい皆様今まで何をお話したかということは
きれいにお忘れになっているかもしれません
で まああまり心配しなくても構いません
なぜならば私も全部忘れちゃったんです
今まで何を喋ったかということ
まあ頭っていうのはすごい早く変わりますからね
体より早くはいろいろ新しい考え方入ったりするし
それによって考え方も変わってしまうんです
であの今日は一応三回目でございまして
えーと まああの皆様にあの報告してあったような順番でいえば
あの釈尊の教導というものは何でしょうかということで
で 前回ではこのいくらか仏教の基本的な考え方説明いたしましたと思います
そこで あの どなたかわかっていませんだけど
最後に質問がありましたね
教祖の方がいらっしゃっている方たち
あの 何て言いますか そういう何でも無常であると
で 変化していくものだとという考え方を徹底的に持っていっちゃうと
現代社会で会社とかね
そういうところでまあ責任なんかはどうしますか？というということで
で 私はその答えは まあちゃんとした答えはまあ今回に持っていきますということに
もう質問の答えはまあ終わったんです
であの まあそれしか覚えてないいませんだけど
じゃあそこから始まります
で そこが始まる前に まあちょっと前に戻って
あのお釈迦様は大体この大変大事に教えたのはこの無常の考え方と
あの物事には実体がないと変化しないという 2つなんですね
で この実体がないということは
このなんか我々にはピンとこない考え方なんです
なかなかピンとこないんです
で なぜピンとこないかというと
私たちは実際に世の中はその通りにあるんではないかとと思ってきたんですよ
世の中 触ったら触れるし
見たら見えるし 聞こえたら聞こえるし
まあ私もここにいるし
皆様もいるし 地球もあるし
宇宙もあるしということで
そこで で 最初の人間っていうのはもういろんなものを見て
まあすごいびっくりして
いろいろ考え方 哲学とかね
まあ発展していきましたけど
どんどん人間はただ思うことは真理だと思ってきたんですね
例えばいきなり洪水が出てきて
あの作物は全部もう消えてしまったと
で すごい不幸になっちゃうんですね
そこでやっぱり我々には何か間違いがあって
バチが当たったんではないかと思う
その思い込みが真理になっちゃうんです
真理になっちゃって やっぱりそういう人間の行いが悪くなったら
罰を与えてくれる誰かがいると
その思い込みが真実になっちゃうんですね
で 我々科学的に歴史たどってみると
原始時代の人々が我々に罰を与えてくれる神がちゃんと見て捕まって
そんな話が言ったんだというのはちょっと信じられ信じがたいなんですね
なぜならば 今もそういう人がいるならば
我々に捕まるはずなんですね
で 遠い昔 人々はこの不幸にあったら不幸をしてくれる
いわゆる罰を与えてくれる神がいるのではないか
それで幸福になってきちゃったら
あの家畜動物はいっぱい子供を産んでくれたりとかね
子供はいっぱい授けたりとかね
あるいはもう農作物はちゃんと雨が降って天気が良くて出てきたらまあ万々歳状態で
やっぱり恵みを与えてくれたというふうなことになってしまうんですね
そこでそう 人間はそう思う
なぜそう思うかというと
わからないんだからなんですね
そこら辺明確に考えてほしい
しっかりとわからない
なんだかわからないんだけど
今年の農作農作物は大変もう実ってもらったと
去年は全くダメでしたということなんですね
そのわからない状態 今は私たちにもありますね
たまに我々の人生の中でもなんかわからないんだけど
物事うまくいく なんだかんだで
うまくいってるんだとちょっと威張ってると
威張ってるともう楽に生活
もう酔って生活していると
どんどんいろんなものちょっと崩れちゃうとわかるんですね
崩れちゃったら何だかんでも崩れて崩れていっちゃうんです
そうすると何か訳の分からないんだけど
何でもこの頃は大変運が悪いんではないかと
何やってもダメではないかというふうに考えちゃうんです
ですから このなぜかということは
いまだに我々はわからないんですね
昔もそれはわからなかったんです
ですから 昔はこの原始時代というか
それ失礼な言葉 差別的な用語ですけど
まあ昔の人々はそういうわからないものに何か自分で思い込んで
何か概念を入れる その概念はそれから独立して本当にいるんだと決めつけちゃう
そこで私たちもその遺伝の流れだから
いまだにわからないものであろうとも
あると確実に信じている
そこでそこに逆らったのは二人しかいないんです
二人で言ったって 二つのシステムしかないんです
一つは古い時代から言えば仏教
もう一つは現代的な科学世界
科学的な世界なんです
その二人とも違う立場で
このわからないものにチャレンジしてみたんですね
それで科学の世界で このわからない世界にチャレンジして
で まあ怖いものは知らないという感じで
で この考えてみたところでいろんなことがわかってくるんですね
わかってくると今までやった概念が崩れちゃうんですね
崩れるとみんなものすごく混乱する
反対もする あんたがたとんでもないことをやっているんではないって
とんでもないことを言っているんではないかと反対していて
まあゆっくりとその反対の言葉が消えちゃって
こちらで発見したものはまあ確立してしまっちゃうんですね
我々よく知っているストーリーなんですけど
地球は丸いと言われてひどい目に遭っちゃったんですね
で でもその人はまあそれでも自分が言ったことはもう丸いことは丸いんだと
もう頑固ど自分の考え方にもう定着していたんだから
まあ殺されてしまっちゃったんだけど
でも今はそんなことはもう何のこともない考え方なんですね
そこで科学の世界は この知らないものにチャレンジする
それはたまにちょっと危険なところもありますよ
で 科学は何だかんでもいいということじゃないんだけどね
たまに大変な危ないこともするんだけど
やっぱり危ない結果もあることはあるんだけど
それなりに我々のいろんな問題を解決してくれて
今の現代社会を作ってるんですね
そこで僕はもう一つ それに据えてこれから言いたいところがあるんですね
その科学の科学者のいろんなテキストとか
僕はこの専門的な本は読めませんだけど
で 一般的な この一般誰にでも読めて理解できるような単純な本しか
僕は頭が悪いんだから読めませんだからね
まあそういうのはまあ読んでみると
この僕は科学の論理はそんなに興味ないんです
この科学者に興味があるんです
新しいものを考え出す人々に対して興味があるんですね
そこで見えるのは その人々もやっぱりいまだにこの知らないものはやっぱりあるという概念にいるんですね
そこはすごく明確なんですね
そこを言ったらちょっとわからないんです
もっとわかりやすく ちょっと簡単に説明またし直せますけど
で とにかくこのものがあると
それはどういうふうにありますかと徹底的に分析していく
で 昔と違って原子という概念が出てきて
原子はまたこれはあるんだと変化しませんと思っていたんです
ですからアトムという名前までつけちゃったんですね
アトムというのはもう切っても切れない
もう個体であるという
後でもっと考えてみたら
いえ アトムは切れないわけじゃなくて
それは中にいろいろものをついているんだと
そこでニュークリアスという核ですか
核というものを発見しちゃうんで
やっぱり核は核で その中にいろいろものは回っているんだというふうな
もうニュークリアスも原子がまた複雑な物質になってしまっちゃったんですね
そこでまたさらに研究しちゃうと
核も割れたりすることは割ったりすることはできるんだと発見しちゃうんですね
割ったところでおびっくりしちゃったんですね
あんな小さな核の中に想像を絶するエネルギーは入ってるんですね
普通の原子っていうのは何のことない
大変親切なものなんですけど
その親切なものの中に一番小さいの中で核をちょっとなんかアタック
何かあのエレクトロンですか
それはスピードを上げて撃つんですね
撃っちゃったらもう割れちゃうんですね
割れたところですごいエネルギーが出てくる
今までの計算には全く合わない
それからまた新しい物理学が出てくるんですね
エネルギーとしてはね
それで核の中にいろいろ素粒子を発見する
で 発見した素粒子は 最終的にはこの素粒子って何ものかとわからないんですね
いまだに たくさんは見つかってますけど
あれ一体何ものかとわからない
そこでさらに考えてみて
素粒子っていうのはなんかクォークスというものから出てきているのではないかと
で クォークスの論理は
物理の論理はとはものすごい違うんだそうです
普通だったらこの引力というものがありまして
一つのものは一つのものに引っ張っちゃうんですね
そこで遠くなればなるほど引力は弱くなるんだと
クォークの場合は逆に遠くなればなるほど引力がすごく強くなるんだというふうな考え方出てきて
まあそれもなんか最近
まあそれの証明したんだというふうな話も
なんかかすかに耳には入ったんです
で そういうふうに物事は
まあに対する理解は発展しているんですね
そこで科学者はいまだに見つかってないのは神様なんですね
で それから人間に魂があるかっていうことはまだ見つかってないんですね
見つかってないんだけど
ヨーロッパの科学者に聞いてみてください
確実にあると言うんです
神様はいると言うんです
ですから 結局昔の人々と我々はそんなに知識的に優れているかなと
結局知らないものはあるとすぐ思ってしまう
言ってしまっちゃう 立派な人を書いてる本でもわかる科学ではわからないものはいっぱいありますから
それを正直に認めるんです
認めるんだけど まあそれは神様がそういうふうに作っているんだと
それでも結論つけちゃうんです
例えば ある人のこの DNA について書いているテキストを読んでみて
DNA の不思議さいろいろ書いてあって
結局そういう不思議な設定はもう神様に作られているんだとも書いちゃうんですね
あれほど科学的なものを書いていて
もうくっだらないんだと
この人はただのもう一人のバカではないかと僕は勝手に決めちゃうんですね
あの一言葉は置いといて
こんな複雑でいまだにわからないものはいっぱいあるんだと
でもこの中には生命の秘密はあるだろうと我々は思いますよと言った方がしっかりするんですよ
余計なもう証拠ないもの持っていかないでね
持ってこないでそこはポイントで仏教は違うんですね
この証拠しないものはあると言わないんですよ
証明していないんだと
ですから それについてしゃべるなと
証明するためには証拠が必要なんですね
証拠がある場合は証明できるんですね
ですから 証拠ないということは
我々の認識に頭に何も入らないということなんですね
その情報が ですから 我々には全く知らない世界で知ることも不可能な世界になっちゃうんですね
知ることも不可能な世界はあるんだというのはバカバカらしいんだと
あってもなくても関係ない
なぜならば 我々の生きる生き方にとってはそれは関係ない
関係あるならば知ってるはずなんですね
この知らない 例えば星占いというものがありまして
信じる人を信じない人がありまして
で 本当にそういうエネルギーは人間に影響あるかないかと考えたりする
なんで星占いの世の中にあるかというと
人間の不幸やら幸福やらわからない
わからないともう何とかの説明は欲しがっちゃう
そこでなんとか何とか星の組み合わせによってあなたは幸福になってます
あなた不幸になってますと
あなたの結婚がなかなかもう長びるのは
こういうこういう星の組み合わせのせいですよとか
なんとか言っちゃう そうするとどうしようもないんですね
宇宙に行って星の位置を変えることはできませんだから
お釈迦様が言うのは それはあなたに何か問題があるんじゃないかと
人はあんたの方に寄ってこないのは
あなたの方に何か人を誘き出すというんですか
追い出される何かあるんじゃないかと
なぜならば 具体的な人間がこちらにいて
具体的な人間があちらにいて
お互いが引き寄せないんだと
というならば こちらに具体的な何か原因があるはずなんですね
そういうふうに探した方がいいというのは
仏教的な まあお釈迦様の考え方なんですね
そこで この 現代の知識
哲学すべてこのものは存在する
あるという基本的な土台に乗って立ち成り立っているんです
これは今から言っているのは
僕はものすごい難しいことを言ってるんです
ですから もしかすると理解できないかもしれません
それまず覚悟しておいてください
これから喋ることは ものすごいもう人間にとっては難しいところなんです
で ものはあるということをまず前提として置いておいて
あるものは何ですかと研究する
科学はそういうものなんです
で そこで仏教でこう言うんですね
これはしょうがないんだと
ものあると思うのはしょうがないんだと
仏教ではこういうことを言ってるんです
物事はもう波動みたいな存在なんです
この地水火風という 4つの素粒子みたいなエネルギーを
エネルギーの存在を仏教で言ってるんですね
地というのは質量と作るエネルギーの波動で質量と重さとかね
で 水というのはお互いに引き寄せる引っ張るエネルギーで
風というのはお互いに引き離すエネルギーで
火っていうのはもう回転させちゃう
変化させるさせるエネルギーであって
そういう4種類の素粒子で考えてもいいのは 4
種類の素粒子のまとめで
今言ってる素粒子の単位ができちゃうんですね
できてもそれはずっと変化しているんです
その変化の中で 仏教では生滅という言葉入れちゃって
生と滅 生まれると消えると
で 大きく分けるんですね
で それ波動なんですね
エネルギーは生まれて消えてと
生まれて消えてと 生まれて消えて生まれて消えていっちゃうと
この波で描く場合は 生まれていて消えてという風に言った方がもっとしっかりするんです
言葉としては ですから
三つに分けちゃうんですね
生まれて いて 消える また生まれて
いて 消えると それ あの
仏教用語ではこういう言葉を付たしているんです
ウッパーダ ティティ バンガという言葉三つ使っているんです
ウッパードっていうのは
もう現れてくる ティティっていうのは現れているという
バンガは消えると で あの
仏教の用語を入れちゃうと
例えば日本語の漢字入れちゃうと
すぐ意味が消えちゃう
ああ そんなことかと 分かってるんだっていうふうに思ってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 分かってると思ったら困るんです
ウッパードは漢字で言えば生なんですね
で ティティっていうのは住という
いる 住むという漢字書くんですね
住生の住 で バンガは滅
で そういう あの まあ一応これはまあ単なるシンボルだからね
言葉っていうのはただのシンボルだから
ですから 一つそのものの存在っていうのは
ここで現れて こうやってこうやって消えるんですね
波なんです そうするとまた波の場合は
物理学的に皆様ご存知ですから
また下行ってまた上来るんですね
波っていうのは そこら辺は仏教で喋れないんです
仏教でも 全然このこの
まあまた波書きましょう
ここにもっと見えるように
波はこういう風なものであるならば
こんなもんなんですね
だからここで生と ここで住と
ここで滅と で 我々知っている世界はそういう世界なんですね
で ここの世界はお釈迦様はさえおっしゃってないんです
で おっしゃらないんですね
じゃあそこはものの存在なんです
で じゃあ科学者はどこで研究するかというと
ここら辺で研究しているんです
ここら辺 例えばあるものはここで生まれたと
ここで生まれて存在していて
どんどん消えていく これすごい早いんです
皆様 電波の速さご存知でしょう
電気はどれくらい早く流れるか
電波どれぐらい早く流れるか
光はどれぐらい早く流れるかと
光の速さっていうのは大体素粒子の速さであって
まあそれ以上速さがあまり科学の世界では考えてないんです
仏教ではもっと早く もう早く物事の変化考えてるんです
ですからすごい早いんです
で 今日の言いたがっているのは
このものが 例えばXという
まあ何でもいいんですよ
人でもいいんです ここに田中さんが立っているいるんだと
で 私がずっと田中さん見ているならば
田中さんずっと変化してるんです
田中という波があるんです
ですから 私はこの波のピークで田中さんという人を見ているんです
もし私がここに立っている私が電波のようにずっと変化しているんだと思っても
皆様にそれでも見えるんです
音？同じこと 例えば音が出てくると
その振動はすーっと変化しているでしょ
音の波が出てくるんですね
音の波なんですけど ずっと耳に聞こえてるんですね
そこで耳に触れるのは
この波の一番 ピークと英語で言うんですけど
日本語の場合は何と言いますか
まあなんか専門用語あるでしょ
物理学では 頂点というんですか
何極 極？一番上？まあ頂点でいきましょう
まあ一般一般の言葉でいいんじゃないんですか
このあまり専門的に僕も物理学知らないんだから
もうそれそれもうただの田舎もんだからね
田舎育ちで このピーで我々に物事を見える
見える 聞こえる 感じる
ですから 例えばこちらに立っているスマナサーラというこの物体が生まれて
行って頂点にいて 消えて
消えちゃって また生まれて
また現れていて また消えると
皆様方ずっと私を見ているでしょう
そこで皆様方見ているのは私が存在している時の状態で
この時の状態あるいはこの波の頂点だけなんです
そこで問題が生まれるんです
だから私に体に変化を起こした音という物質が有の時
ある時だけ耳に触れる
他の時でも耳に触れない
耳に反応しない わかりますか？耳に音が触れる
触れると耳が反応する
それで聞こえるでしょうに
そこで音は生旧滅なんですね
そこで音の時の時は触れたったらもう痛いと感じてわかるのは音やと
で 滅の時は触れないんだから
だから反応しない それでまた時の時耳に触れちゃって反応する
ですから 私の脳細胞が知っているのは音の有の時
頂点の時 時の時 存在している時だけなんです
ですから すべての人間
すべての生命が世界は存在しているんだと思っているのは当たり前で
しょうがない 矛盾はわからない
というポイントなんですけど
ややこしいんですね お分かりになりましたかな
じゃあもっと俗っぽい例で言いましょう
で 箱があって 箱にあの
で何か電気でも電球でもつけちゃって
それはこの暗いところに置いておいて
電気を消えたり 消したり消えたりする
そうすると私は見ている
見えるのは電気が光ると見える
消えたら見えない 暗いところにいるんだから
また光ったら見える また消えたら見えない
でも電気の場合は暗闇も見えるんだから
暗闇は人間に見えますよ
暗いと ですから 消えたり
消えたり 光ったり 消えたり光ったりすることは分かりますけど
そのどんどん消えたり光ったりする
スピードを上げちゃうと
私たちはもうもうやめたと
もうずっと光りっぱなしだと思っちゃう
で これも蛍光灯も同じでしょうに
消えたり光ったり 普通の電球も消えたり光ったりでしょうに
あの megahertz megahertz と書いているのは
どれぐらい速さで消えたり消えたりするという速さなんです
なんと科学者が知ってるんです
東京は megahertz とか
なんかどこか megahertz と二種類ありますね
日本の電気は あれ消える速さなんです
1 秒間どれぐらいですかね
megahertz というんだから
これをまあ頭おかしくなるほど早いんです
だから電気があるんだと思ってしまっちゃう
光があるんだと そこはもっと複雑に考えたって
もっと深く考えたって同じことなんです
だから物事はの本当に
まあここまで言っちゃ言っちゃうと
僕は大変失礼なお釈迦様にも逆らって言ってることになりますから
そこは置いといても この直線の下は上になっても物事には三つのステータスがあるんですね
一つの現象が三つで存在している
一つは生まれる状態 生まれている状態と消える状態
そこで私は知っているのはいる状態だけ
いわゆる 3 分の 1 なんですね
存在の知ってるの 3 分の 2 は知らないんです
そこをこのお釈迦様がおっしゃってない部分に比べてみると
我々は知っているのは 6 分の 1 なんですね
だから音を聞いていても
音の 6 分の 1 しか聞いてないんです
他の存在は知らないんだと
その知ってるものは存在している時
有の時 有と無に分かれると有の時
ですから 世の中の人間みんなものはあるとあると徹底的に思っているんです
で 無常の話 説法で言うでしょう
お坊さんたちは そうするとみんな花が咲いて消えていくんだとかね
おじいちゃんが亡くなっちゃう
やっぱり無常だとかね
地震が起きて建物が壊れたらやっぱり無常だとか
そんな美学的な話じゃないんです
無常っていうのは それで誰が悟りますかというと
そんなにも悟ることもないんだからね
もうちょっとちっさい話なんです
例えば我々知ってる あの花が咲いて消えていくとかね
我々は毎日年取っていくとかね
その無常も結局は無常じゃないんですね
有なんですね だからまあ世の中見て全てのものが変化しているのは見えるでしょうにね
見えてもなかなか心は綺麗にならないんです
お金がなくなっちゃったら
じゃあ頑張ってもう一踏ん張ってまた儲かろうという風になっちゃうんです
どんどん若さが消えていくなと思っちゃったら
じゃあエアロビクスダンスでもやって
エステでもしてもっと若返ってみようではないかと思っちゃうんだから
鏡で見たら年取ったな
やっぱりもう全部消えていくんだと
もう体に執着は何の意味もないんだと思ってはくれませんね
シワが ああ嫌だ シワが出ましたから
何とかしなくちゃとかね
マッサージでもしなくちゃとか
針でも刺してもらわなくちゃとかね
ふうになりますから 無常見えても心はそのまんまで
欲のまんまで で 有しか誰にでも見られません
体験できません 経験できません
そこで有と思っているんだから
まあ大事なものだと取らなくちゃいけないんだと
自分のものにしなくちゃいけないんだと思ったりする
たとえ CD 買って音楽を聴いたっても
同じ物質的に同じものを聞こえると思いますか？ CD 自体もずっと変化していくし
自分がこの機械にかけてそれを回しちゃうと
その時の電気で流れてくるの
じゃあまた明日の聴こうといえば
昨日の電気ですかね 全く違う電気ですからね
その時流れてくる ですからもう二度と聞こえないんです
我々はやっぱりそれでも執着する
前もって予約して CD 買う
買ったものは大事にして
もう毎日聴いたりする
電車でももうずっと聞きっぱなしで
で それで有の世界で生きてるんです
有だけの世界で だから仏教ではこの言ってる科学者言ってることは間違ってはないんだけど
正しくもないんです 私たちに聞こえる音は決して間違ってはないんだけど
全くその通りということでもないんです
まあ 3 分の 1 ぐらいですね
そこは仏教 お釈迦様発見した無常論なんです
それにはこのなぜ瞑想が出てくるかというと
この ああ 見て あの食べ物おいしいんだとか
あの建物は綺麗だとかね
日光は綺麗ですよとかね
あーだこーだそういう感覚ではこんな難しいことはわからないんです
ですから 我々の認識方法さえ変えて
きみ細かく微細に物事を見えるようにする
ほんのわずかなものでも見えるというのを感じるようにする
それは機械はダメなんです
機械で見たっても驚きますけど
例えば電子顕微鏡をなんとか使ってものを見ると驚くでしょうに
怖くてもう生きていられないほど
もう微生物の姿とかね
怖い すごい鬼みたいな姿形取っているんだからね
でも我々は見えないんだから平気で体中ずっともう数え切れないほどいるんですよ
もうすごい倍率の高い顕微鏡で見るとかね
まあ電子顕微鏡のような
ものすごいもう倍率を一番高いものから見ると
もう結構恐ろしいものを見えちゃいますけどね
でもそれ見て感動するかショック受けるならばありがたいんだけど
それでもな 人間っていうのはショックを受けないんですね
なぜかわかりませんだけどね
ですから この このありのままに見るという言葉がございまして
その情報がそのまま流しておいて
解釈しないで この瞬時にそのまま受け取るということを訓練するんです
訓練しちゃったら この
このエネルギーのレベルでもう認識しているんだっていうことをわかるんですね
分かったら ああ やっぱり生滅変化していくんだということに気がつくんです
そこで今まで世の中にあったすべての概念がパッと消えちゃう
あの人は綺麗だから とにかくお金ででも払って
もうもう自分のものにしなくちゃいけないとか
そういうふうな欲の世界はもうそれでもう完璧にもう消えちゃうんです
もう二度とごまかせませんと
そういうのは仏教で言ってるこの最終的な悟りなんです
ですから 一応仏教の悟りはそういうふうに科学的な説明できるものなんです
なんか宗教的な何かもうね
死んでから天国に行くような感じの話ではないんです
まあすごい難しい話になりましたけどね
大体ここら辺のは僕は何回も説明しています
何回説明していても なかなかわかってはいただけません
この前も同じことを言った覚えがあるんです
で また違う 例えます こちらで波を作っている
聞く 見る 感じるという認識するという波がピークの時
頂点の時 外の波 波があるんですから
波と波がぶつかっちゃう
ぶつかったところ その反応は認識するんですね
それを認識と呼ぶんです
ですから 我々の認識 頭の知っているすべてのものはものがあるというところで
自分もない時はもう認識しないし
外の世界はない時も自分が認識しないし
そこは仏教のアビダンマという哲学がございまして
そこら辺ではすごい明確にわかりやすく説明しているんです
それは現代用語に入れ替えちゃったらわかりにくくて難しくなるんです
古い仏教用語で勉強すると
何のこともなく勉強できる
昔のお坊さんたちがね
科学も何もない時代で
こういう考え方はもうとことん当たり前の日常茶飯事でも知っていたんだから
日常茶飯事 それだけじゃなくて
物質の場合は波は大きいし
で あの どれぐらい うの状態でどれぐらい瞬間感じられるかどうかね
そこまで計算しているんです
まあそこ その話はまあ今日関係ないんだから置いておきますけど
で あの 昔からそういう知識が仏教にはあるんです
で 私はちょっと遊びみたいな感じで
この現代用語に入れただけなんですね
いわゆる波という言葉は
仏教でお坊さんたちは使ってないんです
それは私が勝手に使っていることで
波動という言葉も仏教では出てこないし
それ私は勝手に使っている言葉で
それは現代の新聞やら雑誌から僕はまあもう借りた言葉で
そこで問題はですね この波書いちゃったら流れてるんですね
スーッと 1本で その波さえ間違ってるんです
だから仏教で波は書かないんです
なぜならば 例えばここに波はこの物質で書けば
ここに物質は存在しましたと
例えば小さな点で生まれてきて
小さな点で生まれてきて見えないんですね
その点は大きくなって
それからその点はまた小さくなって消えると
そこはそこを波で書けないんです
消えちゃったらもう消えるんです
消えたところでまた小さな点が生まれてきて
大きくなって また小さくなって消える
そこは線で書けば波なんですけど
ですから 仏教では波という言葉を使ってないのは
僕はもうさすが偉いと思っちゃいますよ
これ書いちゃったらもう流れてるんだから
もうあるんでしょうに
波として またあるという邪見に落ちちゃうんですね
だから仏教ではもう波という言葉使ってないな
僕はやっぱりすごいなと
なぜならば もう言葉あるんだから使っちゃえばいいのにね
使ってない だけど私は勝手にものすごい
まあまあ勉強それほど深い勉強してないんだから
まあいい加減そういう波なんか描いたりして
結局間違っちゃいますけどね
じゃあ で どんなものでもない状態からどんどん現れてきて
消えていっちゃう またどんどん現れてきて
また消えていっちゃう
またどんどん現れてきて
それで現れてきて 大きくなっちゃったら
これ知ってるんです こちらは
そこで消えると知らない
また現れるとまた知ってるんですね
そこでこっちはこの人はあるんだと思っちゃう
それ説明するためにも素晴らしい例えが日本にあるんです
達磨さんが転んだという遊びがあるんですね
あの遊びはまあ実際には正しくできませんだけど
あの遊びは理想的に考えてみてください
達磨さんが転んだっていうのは
あの鬼たちがいろいろ鬼たちではなくて
遊んでいる子供たちはいろいろふざけて遊んでいる
そこで鬼になっている子はこうやって見るとみんな止まっちゃうんですね
だからみんな止まっていて
また向こうあっち向いたらまたいろいろ変化して
こっち見たらまた止まっている
それは厳密に計算してみてください
もし厳密に考えちゃうと
その人は見ない時はいわゆる認識しない時は動いてるんです
認識する時は動いてないと
もしその子がこれあくまでもこの頭の中の遊びですけど
ある子供たちが遊んでいると
そこでこの鬼になっている子が振り向くたびに
みんないろいろ変化してある形になるんだと
例えば右手を上げて立ってる形になってるんだと
そうするとこの子は 10年間でも振り向いてみても
みんな手を上げて立っているという固定しているように解釈しちゃうでしょ
なぜならば 手を下げている時
座っている時は見えなかったんだから
ですから この達磨さんが転んだという方式で
よくもこの真理の方式に遊びができたもんですよ
また考えちゃうと方式なんです
ものはある瞬間で知る
ない瞬間では知らない
当たり前のことなんですから
ですから 知ってるものはあるものは知ってるんだから
ものはあると決断しちゃう
決めてしめちゃう ですから
知ったものは正しい でしょ
正しくないわけないんです
決断したことは間違い
だからあるんだと思った言葉だけ間違いであって
音は聞こえたということは正しい
だから音があると それは間違いと
あの あの人何ですかって
コギトという言葉言った人がデカルトだから
で 私は考える それは正しい
だから私がいる それはもう×と
それだけのことなんですね
ですから 仏教の難しい立場というのは
人の考え方はなかなか否定もできないし
肯定もできないんですよ
どんな教えにしても 哲学にしても
宗教にしても 例えば仏教とキリスト教といえば全く違う宗教
2つでしょうに 私は仏教徒と信じているんだから
キリスト教は間違ってるんだと言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
そんな簡単に言えないんです
キリスト教とイスラム教
お互いに喧嘩していますけど
あの人は間違ってる こちらこちら間違ってると
僕らから見れば別に間違っていると間違っていないとどっちでも言えないんです
どんなものについていても
そういう風な この なんかちょっとややこしい立場なんですね
世の中の一般的に見たっても同じことでしょ
例えば納豆は体にいいでしょ
それ問題ないんだけど
じゃあだからといって納豆ばっかり食べてみてください
そうすると体にいいわけじゃなくて体壊れる
壊せるんですよ 病気になっちゃいしまうんです
とんでもない病気になるかもしれませんね
ずっと朝も昼も夜も 納豆とご飯だけ食べてみてください
ということは 納豆は体にいいということは
いい側面があるということなんです
完璧に完全にいいということじゃないんです
うなぎもいい食べ物で皆様ご存知でしょうね
じゃあ 1週間ぐらいでもうなぎだけ食べてみてください
確実に病気になると思いますよ
体の調子が悪くなると思いますよ
ですから 大体即的な世界に世界見ても
そんなにこれはこれと
これはこれと言えたもんじゃないんです
言えません だからあまり喧嘩するなと
これは私の意見だ あなたの意見が間違っているんだとかね
落ち着けと だから頭のこういうことを知っている人は
もう何のことなく落ち着いているんです
何についても 例えば日本の新聞の中で一番いい新聞は何ですか？と言ったら
そんなものあるわけないでしょうに
何か買う時でもね どんな服が一番いいものだ
そんなものあるんだったら
みんないっぺんに来て全部買ってしまっちゃいますけど
そんなもの世の中にないんです
みんなそれはそれなりに結論をつけてるだけで
仏教ではこの結論というものはつけない
つけないのはもう何もわからないんだからではなくて
分かっているんだからなんです
だからこの大乗仏教を使っていることは
空という言葉しか使う方法がないんです
でも お釈迦様は全ては空だという言ってない
なぜならば 言っちゃったらまた言っちゃったことになっちゃいますから
それは間違いです ですから
そこら辺まで微かにお釈迦様は違うんです
空っていう言葉はお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
一切は空であると一切は皆空であるっていうのはお釈迦様の言葉じゃないんです
それはもうそれ以降 後で哲学者から作った言葉なんです
哲学者はやっぱり私は考える
だからいるという立場でやってますから
仏教のお坊さんたちも
まあ全ては無常で空ですから
何も実体はない じゃあ全ては無常空だと決めて膨大な哲学を書いちゃったんですね
あれにしても仏教 お釈迦様から見れば同じ態度なんですね
やれやれと もうもう一つできたんだと
それだけ あんまりそんなに大胆でもないんですね
せっかくものがいて ゆっくり減って消えちゃう
消えてまた現れてくる
そこで我々はこのはめられてる
もう一つのものがあるんですね
例えば この眼鏡が完璧に消えるんです
消えて これは牛でもいいんだけど
トカゲでもいいんだけど
ヘビでもいいんだけど
ヘビのような形に変化するんだったらわかるでしょうに
眼鏡が無常だから ある瞬間眼鏡で
ある瞬間ヘビで ある瞬間はもうもうこのガラスで
ある瞬間はカバンになったりすると分かりますでしょう
明確に そうすると 眼鏡になった時だけ目に掛けて文字が読めると
そういう風にあるならば
そんなに難しいことを言わなくたってもいいんですね
でも 消えたものが その新しいものを作る時は
前のものとほぼ似ているものを作っちゃうんですね
ということは 皆様方 金運の塊持ってきて叩いて
もう溶かして何を作っても
それは金でできたものになっちゃうし
土にはなりませんね ご飯なんか持ってきて
どんな工夫したっても金にはならないんですね
昔あったんですね この金を合成するアルケミという何？錬金術
みんなよくバカなこと考えちゃったんですね
まあいろいろ工夫したら金ができるだろうと
でもできないんですよ
ですから この消えたものに似ているんですね
生まれたものは そこで消えた原因で生まれるんですね
そこで仏教のこの因果論ですか
中道っていうのは因果論なんですね
出てくるんです いわゆる一つ消えちゃうと新しいものが現れますけど
その消えるものによって現れるものは決める決められますね
ですから 我々の好き勝手に無責任でいろんなことを行動することはできないんです
例えば悪いことをしたならば
無常だからどんな結果でもいいんじゃないかと
そんな甘くはないんです
その行為にふさわしい結果が出てくる
それはもう避けられない
誰にでも どう頑張っても
まあわかりやすい世界に戻ったら
例えば高い品物を買いたいんだとという結果があるならば
それだったら大金を持たなくちゃいけないんですね
だから大金は消える 原因によって高い品物は買えると
それも決まっていて 変化できません
そこで因果論というものは出てくるんです
それに仏教は因果論といって
因縁という縁も必要なんですね
例えば大金があるんだからって
高い品物を買えるわけでもないんです
いろいろ条件もあります
全部揃ったらその結果が出てくる
そういうわけで 物事はあるということをみんな決めてしまっちゃう
例えば私の体 医学的に見てください
母のお腹で目に見えないほど小さい 1個の細胞でしたし
その細胞がその細胞自体が死んじゃうでしょうね
死んで分解するでしょ
で 新しい細胞 それから出来てきて
赤ちゃんの時あった細胞は今一つも持ってないんです
両親から頂いた細胞というのは全くまるっきり今持ってないんです
僕は日本にすごい長い時間いたんだから
長い間いたんだだから今この体の全細胞が日本から得た物質でできているんです
いわゆる 100% のメイドインジャパンなんです
この体が でも私は日本人ではありませんね
いまだに外人なんです
いまだに外国の国籍なんです
いまだに日本の入国管理局にいじめられるんですね
それはなぜですかと だから
この消えるものについて作る新しいものは
消えたものに似ているんです
私も皆様も同じ食べ物を食べているでしょうし
でも私の細胞を壊しちゃったら
日本の店から買った材料を入れて
それで新しい細胞を作るんだけど
壊れた細胞と似ているものを作るんですね
皆様 同じ店でパン買って食べても
私と一緒に 皆様の細胞壊れたら
それにあのパンにある原料をもらって
それで新しいものを付けちゃう
で 似てるんですね 消えたものに
私の体も同じく ですからもう 100年経って
皆様と一緒に全く同じものを食べても
私はそれでも外人で違う人で
皆様は日本人で それはもう変わらないんですね
そこら辺はあまり理解しないんだから
ちょっと問題であると
そういうことで 仏教のカルマ論というものは出てくるんですね
無常でもありながら カルマの働きもあるんだと
ですから 人に嘘をついちゃったら
それなりに私は不幸に出会うんです
どういう風な不幸になるかということはまた決まっているんですね
いくらかは ケチをつけちゃったら
もう財産はなくなっちゃうんだと
それはもうその通りになっちゃうんです
それに神様は要りませんでしょ
誰かそんなあなたケチをしたんだから
あなたの財産を奪っちゃいましょうとかね
そういう必要ないんだよ
これは法則なんです そういう法則なんですね
でもそこに変化しないものは何もないんだと
変化しないものは何もない
だからこの体見たら 全ての細胞が全く 3ヶ月とかで全部生まれ変わってるんだから
でも違う人間だとも言えないんですね
例えば僕は半年前に人をぶん殴ったと
そこで半年経ってその人を私また会ったところで
その人 あなたはその半年前に私をぶん殴ったでしょう
今日はやり返しますと言ったら
僕はやめてくださいと
その時あなたは 殴った人がもうすでにいないんだと
もう全部その細胞も死んでしまって
もう新しい もうパン食べて鶏食べていろんなものが新しいものですよ
今はぶん殴ったらいけませんと言っても
それではうまくいかないんですね
そうすると私も 私はあなたには殴ったことないでしょうに
その時私は殴った人はもうすでにないんだから
死んでるんだから だからあなた今更なんですかと
そう言っても そうはうまくいかない
なぜならば この今の瞬間の品物を消えちゃったら
次に現れる品物は前の品物に似ていて
前の品物の原因で現れちゃうんです
それもエネルギーの法則なんです
そこは今日のテーマなんです
お釈迦様が発見した中道っていうのは因果法則なんです
なぜそれに中道と言いますかというと
インド人はもっと簡単に物事を考えたんです
インド人はこの例えばこの赤ちゃんが生まれて大きくなって死んでしまっても
なんか自分自分が自分いるという実感があるんですね
ですから無常を見ないで
やっぱりいるんだと いるというその実感自体は変化
消滅 変化しない霊魂だと
例えば椅子なんか机なんか見ても
なんか椅子見たっても同じく見えちゃうんですね
ですから そういうものも何か実体としてあるんだと言うんです
それはお釈迦様はその人々は物の一つの側面しか見ていないんだと
どんな側面という 見てないんだと
そこでエターナリズムというあまり聞き慣れてない英語の単語なんですけど
それにはこの日本語の辞書では言葉ないんです
英語のヨーロッパの人だったらごく普通の当たり前の言葉なんです
エターナリズム この でも皆様はエタニティという言葉知ってるかもしれません
こういう言葉は知ってるでしょう
エターナル エタニティ
エターナルというのは永遠
エタニティは永遠でエターナルっていうのは永遠的な形容詞なんですね
変化しない永遠という意味で
これを哲学としてエターナリズムと言うんですね
でもなんか適当な 言葉は私の頭にはないんです
日本語の言葉は で で 物事のこの生まれるということを見る
見てあるということだけ見て
昔インドではやっぱり全ては実体としてあるんだと決めてしまっちゃったんですね
で 現代的な宗教でいえば
この梵が一如とか 永遠なる神たる魂と我々の魂は全部一つでも一際にあるんだと
いろいろ哲学がたくさんあったんです
できたんです そこでもう一つの人々が物事を消えることを見ていたんですね
何でも消えてしまう 見たら赤ちゃん可愛い可愛いと思ったっても
もうどんどんどんどん消えちゃって
もう可愛くない大人になってしまうし
で 種植えちゃっても どんどん変化して花咲いてまた消えてしまうし
結局なんだかんだ消えちゃうんだと思って
消える部分だけ見て空だけ見て
今日無主義何もないんだと
魂も何もないんだと 全く無だと
皆無だと 皆無論作っちゃうんですね
今日無主義 それは私は英語の単語しかなかなかわかりませんので
英語ではニヒリズムというんですね
結論言ってる人はニヒリスティックじゃないんです
ニヒリズムを言ってるわけじゃなくて
物質の存在を認めているんだから
半分ニヒリズムで 半分エターナリズムで
それであの全て魂で霊魂だけですよと言っている人々いるんですね
物質は否定する その人々はまた半分エターナリズムで
半分ニヒリズム ですから
世の中で厳密にエターナリズムとニヒリズムを喋っていたのは
お釈迦様がいた時代の人々だけみたいんですね
そこら辺はすごい難しい世界だから
まあ理解しなくたっていいんです
とにかく お釈迦様は簡単にこう言うんですね
物事は生まれてくること
その側面だけ見ている人々はものは存在していると言うんだと
物事は消えていく それだけ見て人々は物事は全部存在しないんだと言うんだと
でも私は中道をとって語りますよと
因縁あるとこういう果が出てくるんだと
その因縁が消えたらその果も消えていくんだと
原因があると果が出てきて
その原因が消えるとその果が消えてしまうと
そういう因果法則のシステムがお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
そこは半分エタニティズム
半分ニヒリズムというところじゃないんです
それに高いレベルの教えなんです
因果法則 で それはまあそれぐらいのことでいいんです
今日は あまりこの理解しなくても結構です
ですからね 物事はいろんな原因があって生まれてきて
原因で生まれたならば
その原因消えると消えてしまうんですね
ですから 物はあるとは言えないし
ないとも言えないんです
ただ 原因に一時的に支えられているだけ
そこで正しい原因を探してほしい
間違っている原因じゃない
そこで間違うんです みんな
正しい原因というのは
消えたらすぐ結果が消えちゃう
例えばこの蛍光灯光っていると
原因は電気が流れている
それは正しい原因 原因
電気の流れを止まってみてください
すぐ蛍光灯も消える そういうふうなこの正しい因果法則を探さなくちゃいけない
それはこの結果の中に
そこにあるんです あの世にあるわけじゃないんです
神様のところにあるわけじゃないんです
例えば このガラスの中に水があると
それに原因は神様のところに探すんですかね
この水に 水がここにあるということは
ガラスという入れ物に支えられているんだから
ですから そこに原因があるんです
だから遠く行かないんです
真理探すために 例えば
私のお腹が痛い それはアメリカのユタ州に住んでいる人のせいですよと言ったら意味がないでしょうに
私のお腹が痛いならば
そのそこら辺に原因があるんです
ですから 仏教はあの世には行かないんです
真理探すために この体の中で真理を探しちゃうんです
僕はすごい科学的だと思いますよ
それしか正しい方法ないと私は思っているんです
他の方 皆様はどう思っていたっても
それは私に関係ないんだけど
[背景音楽]原因はそこに結果のところにあるんです
そこら辺も仏教とは他の世界とは違うポイントなんです
ですから いろいろ瞑想すると
この超自然的な誰かから降りてきて
智慧が現れてくるとか
そういう風な概念はお釈迦様の瞑想ではないんです
外から知恵が現れてこない
こちらで生まれる ですから
お釈迦様はこういうふうなことを言うんです
すべてのことを知りたければ
一切智者になりたければということで
この体のことを勉強しろと
これを勉強しろ そうすると一切は知ってるんだと
宇宙の果てまで見てやろうと思ったっても
全然見ることは不可能なんです
知ることも不可能なんです
知ってもそんな知ってるものは正しくもないんです
ですから お釈迦様はイマスミンイエバビャーママッタケカレバレローカンチャパンニャペミローカサムダヤンチャローカニロダンチャという言葉で抑えまして
このビャーママッタカというのは長さなんですね
いわゆる 1メートルぐらい
この 1メートルぐらいのこの体の中に
私は世界すべてをあると言いますと
世界の現れ方 世界の消え消えていくことと
世界を脱出することと
全部このここにあるんだと
その場合は世界というのはすべてという言葉を使っているんです
他のところですべては何ですかと
あなた方に私はすべては教えますと言って
すべては何ですかと言って
お釈迦様は色受想行識のこの体ですよと
そういうのは その言葉だけ聞くとそんなに大胆に聞こえませんだけど
こういう考え方から見てください
どれほど優れている考え方かと理解できると思います
原因結果論から因果法則から見ると
結果因と一緒にいないと
例えば包丁でリンゴを割ると
リンゴを割ったという結果でしょうに
包丁が台所にあって こちらにあるリンゴがあって割れるわけないでしょうに
そこにあるんです 原因結果が
ですから 知りたいならばそこに探すんです
ということで お釈迦様の道なんですね
で 大体それはお釈迦様
中道という名前で言ってるんです
なんか皆さんは大変難しい話になりまして
申し訳ないんですけど
何か今日は もしかすると私は元気じゃないかもしれません
元気がなくなっちゃうと
どの話が難しくなるんです
で 工夫しないんですね
頭の中でそのまま喋っちゃうんです
質問していいですか？はい
釈迦に対してですね 神とは何ですか？という質問をしたとしますね
そうしますと 釈迦はですね
どういうふうに答えると先生はお考えになりますか
ですね だからお釈迦様は大体あなたは神と何を考えているんですかと
相手のこの理解をまず聞いてもらうんです
なぜならば この言葉というのはすごく危ないもので
私は神と何か思っていて
相手方が何か神かと思っていて
そうするとこちらで喋ったっても話合わないんですね
ですから まずお釈迦様だったら
じゃあ神って神だと あなたは何を思ってますかと
と聞くんです 聞いたら相手方は説明するんですね
そこでお釈迦様は答えるんです
そういうものだったら
こういうことだよと インドではこの絶対神という概念は何かそれほど発展してなかったんですね
絶対というテクニックなことは発展してなかったんだけど
あったんですね もうあんまりにも発展しすぎて分かりやすくなっていただけなんです
で そこであるブラマン人が修行していたんですね
修行じゃなくて お経 自分のお経をあげたり
いろいろ儀式をやったりしていたんですね
そこでお釈迦様はその人に会って
あんた方は何やってるの？って言ったら
その人とは我々の伝統ではこういうお経をあげたり
そういうこういう儀式をすると
確実に梵天と一緒になるんだと
教えられているんだと
と聞くんですね あなたはどう思いますか？と
言ったら その場合はお釈迦様も同じ系統で勉強していたんだから
その人々も勉強同じだから
お互いに話が通じちゃうんですね
在って このそのブラフマン人が梵天と思ったことは知っているんです
だからお釈迦様はこう言うんです
じゃああなたに聞きますけど
梵天の特色は言ってくださいと
言ったら 梵天は大慈悲である
慈しみの状態であって
この慈悲喜捨なんですね
それからもう悲しんでいる人を助けるエネルギーであって
喜びであってとかね もうそれからもう平等な精神的なレベルである存在ということは
もうブラフマン系統でも見ていた
考えていたんですね 神に対して
そうすると お釈迦様はこういうふうなことを言うんですね
あなた方はね 川のここ側いて向こう側に行きたい
そこで川の向こう側よ
こちらにおいでください
なぜならば ここ側は大変危険であって
不幸であると 私は幸福たる向こう側に行きたいんだと
一生懸命歌ってみてくださいと
川の向こう側 こっち来るんだと
来るかと 来ないだろうと
じゃあ知識のある人はどうするんです？と言ったら
いかだでも作って向こうに行くんだと
ですから もし神は慈しみ
慈しみであるならば あなたは自分の心で慈しみさを育てなさいと
無料で無制限でありとあらゆる生命に対する慈しみさを広げなさいと
そうすると あなたは梵我一如になるんだと
そういうふうに合理的に答えちゃうんですね
それまたお釈迦様は正しく答えているんです
でおっしゃった通りの質問が一つあるんです
経典の中で王様が 孝宗王様が来て
世の中で神がいるんですかと聞いたんです
その場合の神は違うんです
この八百万の神なんです
もう日本でもあるでしょう
あっちこっちで神様がいるというふうな
もうあっちこっちちょっと拝んだりとか
ちょっとお供えして何かとか
そういうふうにこの人間守ってくれる
この複数の多層の神々の考え方なんですね
もしかすると王様があっちこっちいろんな神社みたいなものを見て
もうなんかお釈迦さんにこれ聞いてみようかなと思って
面白半分で聞いたかもしれません
聞かれたらお釈迦様は何か世の中そういう考え方もあるみたいよと言ったんです
世の中でなんかそんなような考え方もあるみたいねと答えるんですね
答えたら王様がそう言われるとわからないんだと
僕は本当に神がいるかないか知りたいんですよと言ったら
お釈迦様はこう言うんです
私はこういうふうに答えたならば
知識人がいるだろうと理解するんだと
お釈迦様の答えのこのややこしさというのはすごいんです
私は世の中でまあそんな考え方もありますよと言ったならば
やっぱりおそらくあっちこっち神々がね
宿っているでしょうとかね
知識人は理解するんだと言うんですね
そのお釈迦様の心の働きっていうのは
すっごくもうレベル高いんですね
そこでお釈迦様はもう罠にはめられませんし
神がいると思っちゃったら
この神の概念 概念相違でしょ
相違ます 現代人物は お釈迦様は神を認めているんだから
何で仏教の人々は神様を信じてないかとか言われるかもしれませんし
そこまで考えちゃう概念が曖昧だからもうはめられませんし
だからといって超次元的な生命はないとは言いたくないしね
お釈迦様は知ってるんだからって話したりもしているんだから
人間が神というのは一番超次元的な存在なんですね
ですから まああっちこっち神様がいるんだと思って人間拝んだりするのは
まあまあそれなりにいいんじゃないかと
という立場で それでもいいですよと言っちゃったら
みんなそこをやっちゃうでしょうに
人間というのは今 現代 21世紀になりかかっているんだけど
我々はあっちこっちで拝んだりしたいでしょ
気持ち正直なところは
病気になったらそれなりの神社があるならばありがたいことで
安産のための神社があるならばありがたいことで
縁結びの神社があるならばありがたいことで
物事を簡単に便利に済みますからね
安くて ですから 人間はその気持ちはなくなりません
だからお釈迦様はそれはいいですよと
やってくださいと言っちゃったらどうなるんですかね
人間が また迷信の海に迷信の森に迷い込んじゃうでしょ
ですから お釈迦様は答えなくて
そういう考え方が世の中にありますと
もし反対だったら 綺麗にそれは間違いだと言うんです
そういうことなんだよ
お釈迦様の答えは ある一回
私はあるキリスト教のプロの方が
聖職の方が神について
ブッダについて質問したんですね
僕は最初にその人は聖職者だとは知らなかったんです
ただ 僕は見たのはただの外国人で
ヨーロッパ人なんですね
それで僕は勝手に考えちゃった
ヨーロッパ人はもう神は信じてるんだと
この人は私に仏教のことを聞いてるんだと
私は仏教という宗教あるんだから
ヨーロッパ人の考え方よりもこちらの方がすごい優れてるんだと
ちょっと自慢しなくちゃいけないんだと
ただ自慢したって馬鹿にされるんだから
それすごい工夫しなくちゃいけないなと思って
僕はこう言ったんですね
で あなた方はある絶対的な存在によって全てはできているんだと思っているかもしれませんと
我々は法則４つがありまして
その法則によって宇宙が成り立っているんだと
そこには人格的なものはないんだと
と言って 法則のことをちゃんと説明してあげたんです
言ったら その人はやっぱり私たちの宗教でも神っていうのは人格では見ないんだと
何かそういうふうな この支配している法則のように見ているんだと
そうすると似ているんだと
まあそれぐらい言うならば似ていますよと
言っても その人はやっぱり私の話のすごいきめ細かく説明しましたから
そこまでそこは発展せてないこと知ってるんだからね
まあ向こうはどんなカード持ってるかっても最初から知ってるんだから
別に勝負になりませんだけどね
で 向こうはそれからずっと私の弟子になったみたいな感じで
なんだかんだ教えてください
教えてください 教えてくださいと
すごい迷惑になっちゃったんだけどね
後でちゃんとした聖職者とプロであることを分かったら
それは良くないんだと
その人は自分の宗教をやらなくちゃいけない
私の話を聞いちゃってね
自分の信仰を失っちゃって
なんか行く道が生きる道が消えちゃったら大変だからね
僕はその人のことを大変心配して
できるだけカットしてカットしてね
もうカット完璧にカットしましたけど
後で でまあ仏教徒になりたいというのであれば
それは別の話なんですよ
でも自分の人生も考えなくちゃいけないんだからね
ですから まあその神という概念は色々変化しちゃうし
否定もできない 肯定もできない状態なんですね
ですから 相手方がどんな概念を持ってるかということによります
例えば親分みたいな人がいるというと反応が違う
これは宇宙の法則だと言ったら
僕らは全然そうでしょうと言うしか方法ない
例えば ある人は私は神様を信じている
神様っていうのは宇宙の法則ですよというならば
その通りですと そうすると神様を認めたことになっちゃうんです
ある人はもう田中さんかジェホワかアッラーかどっちでもいいんだけど
アフラ・マズダでもいいんだけどという神様が信じているというならば
僕らはちょっとどうかなと
その人はちょっとおかしいんじゃないかと
そのアフラ・マズダさんが宇宙全部作っちゃったんだけど
変なもの作っちゃったんだから
ちょっと頭おかしいんではないかと反論する
そういうことなんです
で まあそういうことで
全ては無常で消えていくんだけど
我々には徹底的な責任がやっぱり追っかけてくるんです
今悪いご飯食べちゃったら
この体がもう壊れて自分が痛い目に遭わなくちゃいけない
悪いご飯食べたんだから元気になったっていうことは成り立たない
私は仕事を失敗したら
私はその分を責任を持たなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 消えるものがそれに似ているものを作る
似ているものを作る その言葉きちんと覚えておいてください
同じものを作るんじゃなくて
似ているものを作る で
体の細胞が鶏の細胞の物質からできてるでしょ
鶏と豚とか魚とかね キャベツとかジャガイモとか
その中にアミノ酸がアミノ酸やらこの DNAを作る材料があるんです
それを持ってきて ここに入れ替えちゃって作ると
新しい DNA が前に亡くなった DNA と似ているんです
でも 質としては全く違う
鶏の体なんです 鶏と豚とか牛とかキャベツとかホウレンソウとかね
ご飯とか お母さんの体じゃないんです
でも やっぱりそれでも母と父の遺伝の癖は持ってるんです
そういうあの法則なんですね
で 8時まででしたっけ 8
時半まで じゃあ一応難しい話はね
ここら辺に置いておいて
もっと分かりやすい 具体的な中道という
お釈迦様が発見した中道のもっとこの論理ではなくてね
分かりやすい世界にちょっと考えてみましょうね
中道というのは素晴らしい
世の中で人間にはほとんど無名の立場なんです
今までの説明でわかりますでしょうに
すぐ我々は偏見的な立場でいるんです
例えば 皆様は私を外人だと見る
それは偏見なんです 私は皆様方は日本人だと見ている
それも偏見なんです 世の中にある考え方というのは全て偏見ばっかりなんです
正しくはないんです じゃあ間違ってますかと
別に間違ってるわけじゃないんですよ
問題は間違いか正しかと決めることで
その代わりに違いますよと言った方がね
ちょっと違うんだと でも日本語で違いますよと言うことは丁寧な否定なんですね
ちょっとした丁寧な言葉だけでね
あんたそれ間違ってますよとはすごい失礼で
ちょっと違いましょう
違いますよと言ったら丁寧な言葉で
でもそれはこの間違じゃなくて
ちょっと違いますよと
という立場なんです その立場で我々も生きていればいいんじゃないかと
ですから 世の中で生きていると
これを考えてみましょう
みんな我々にいろんなことを言う
すると すぐそれはその通りだと決めちゃうでしょうに
それもちょっと気をつけた方がいい
言うことは全くその通りじゃない
大嘘をつける時もありますよ
あのどこかで原子力発電所ですか
事故を起こしちゃった
すぐ何の放射能もないと徹底的に公の報告あったんですね
報告聞いた瞬間に僕は完璧に嘘やと思ったんです
これは完璧な嘘やと それも公の報告なんですね
政府の報告なんです そういう人々も嘘を言うんです
そこでまたちょっと研究したところで
ほんのちょっと漏れたんだと
それはもう全然人体に影響がないんだと
また研究しちゃうと 証拠隠滅やら何から何まで出てきて
それについていちいち喋ると
僕はずっとそれを見ていて
まあそうかそうか まあそうそう
それだけ 他の人々はなんでこんな情報を隠したんですか
それはけしからんだとか
もう感情的になっちゃうんです
僕は別に まあどうせ同じことを 2度ともやりますよと
また他のところで同じ事故を起こしちゃったら
同じ順番でいくんです
まず何の問題もありません
心配するな それは解決しましたという報告
それから ほんのほんの少々の放射能が漏れたんだけど
それをきちんとシールしているんだとか
そういうふうに順番で言って
どれぐらいになったと
そういう同じことを外国で起こったならば
ものすごい神経質になって
ものすごいさんざん悪口言うと
日本の方々は 自分の国で起きたら
それはとにかく消そう
消そう 結局みんな同じことやってるんです
ですから この人々 だからその神経質になったりして感情的になったりすると生きていられないんです
知識的な生き方ではないんです
だからクールになりましょう
物事について 例えば ソ連の方々はね
共産主義のシステムが崩壊することはすごい待っていて
待っていて  1 日も早く壊してほしいとかね
そこで世界中の資本主義の国々がみんな応援して
壊せ 壊せ 壊せと 僕だけ一人で心配していたんです
ソ連の国民のこと 僕は共産主義者じゃないんです
全く反対なんです 共産主義には
反対ですけど 僕は人間のことすごい気になるんですね
人間が苦しんでいるか
幸福であるか 食べているんですか
食べてないんですかとかね
すごく気になっちゃうんです
何もできませんだけどね
気にはなるんです 気持ちとしてはみんな幸福で平和で生きていたいという
僕はみんなと喧嘩するんだけど
もうわずかにでも人をいじめたいという気持ちはないんです
やっぱりみんな私に喧嘩売れたらみんな元気になってほしいだけなんですね
ですから このそれが気になっちゃうんです
どうかな こんな人々 いきなりこんなもう 70年間でしたっけ
随分昔から共産主義のシステムになって
考え方も生き方も何から何まで共産主義であって
いきなりこんな資本主義の世界っていうのはどうかなと
無茶苦茶になるだろうと
これには 10年かかるだろうと
慣れるまではと と思って
やっぱりこちらで壊してやるならば
10年間ぐらいは面倒見なくちゃいけないんじゃないかと
ご飯食べて生きていられるまではと
でもみんな無責任で壊せ壊せ
共産主義は嫌だとか それだけでしょ
ですから 僕にはそれ全部見えるんですね
単なる共産主義は嫌いな私でも同じなんですけど
抱かれて壊せ壊せというのは
やっぱりそれはちょっと無責任だと
人の気持ちは考えていない
ただ一側面だけ見ていると
そこで崩壊しましたでしょ
どうなったんですか 世界一麻雀国になっちゃったんです
世界一すごい強い国が
僕はすごく悲しく思ったんです
あのすごいこのでっかい体を持ってる立派な人々が
汚い商売までやったり
体まで売ったりして 何か食べ物を探そうとかね
ですから そういう世界を見て
中道の立場で世界を見ていると
もうあれはいいや これは悪いやと何か言えなくなっちゃうんです
誰の肩も持てなくなっちゃうんです
誰とも喧嘩できなくなっちゃうんです
なんとなく理解して ああそうですねとかね
理解して それなりにできるだけのことを自分でしてあげて
クールにいられるんです
それはこの今からこういうところから出てくる実践的な知恵なんです
特にこの仏教という教えが誰とも戦わない教えなんですね
戦う必要ないんです 特にあなた仏教徒になりなさいという一言葉言ってはいけないんです
僕はすごい気をつけているんです
もう何年もずっと日本でやってますけど
仏教の運動というか まあ自分が自分の仕事をやってるだけで
一人にも言ったことがないんです
それは良くない で なぜならば
あなた仏教徒になりなさいということは
あなたの生き方は間違ってますよということでしょうに
別に間違ってますかね
完璧に そうでもないでしょ
もし人が今まで私の生き方よりはこの道の方がもっとしっかりしているんだから
やっぱり仏教で実践した方がいいなと思うならば
それはその人の責任で
そこで仏教 我々仏教徒は仏教だと言っている方々が日本にいますよ
あの上座部仏教も 私は上座部仏教しか知りませんだからそれしかやったことがないという方々はいらっしゃいますけど
だからといって僕はあなたは完璧な上座部仏教の信者さんだと判子を押してあげないんです
それは不可能です なぜならば
その人は全部分かったということでもないし
その人は自分がいくらかは理解して
それなりに活動しているだけで
だからあの人は私のことを褒めても
僕はかすかにでも心の中でよかったと思うないんです
かすかにでも 私をなんとなく機嫌を取ってやろうと思って
いくら褒めても全く無駄と思いますよ
なぜかというと 全然ああそうよかった
ああよかった よかった
我ながらよく頑張ったとかね
自分を褒めません それを僕はどう見ていますかというと
この方がこの問題はこのように見ているんだと
たまに人が大変親切に丁寧に私に言うんです
今日の話はよく分かりましたと
大変よかったと で 普通の世界だったら喋った人は喜ぶでしょうね
いい話しました 自分にもなかなかできる
できそうやと こうなっちゃうと私はならないんです
私はこう考えるんだ この方が今日の話は理解しましたと
で 私にとっては話は全く不完全であるということを知っているんです
言いたいものは言えなかったし
簡単に説明しようと思ったところはむちゃくちゃ難しいになっちゃうし
そういう欠点だらけなんですね
講演自体は それでも一人二人が理解するかもしれません
だからその方は私のことを褒めても
それはその方の理解であって
普遍的な真理にはならないんです
そこで私は貶しちゃうと
私は機嫌が悪くなりますかというと
全然悪くならない そんな難しい話は嫌ですよとかね
全然わからないんですよとかね
言われても 僕はこの方には理解できないみたいと
それで終わる でも私は褒めることよりは批判することは真面目に聞く
それはなぜかというと
私は欠点だらけであること当たり前だから
自分の欠点一つ二つ教えてくれると
それは直せるんですね
もし話が難しいと言ったならば
じゃあ今度は簡単にするぞと
と簡単にする ですから
褒め言葉は聞かない 批判の言葉は真面目に聞く
だからでかすかにでも怒らない
でも人間だから何か遊びたい気持ちはいつでもあるんですね
だからいろいろふざけて
いろんな言い返しはしますよ
たまにきつい言い返しもしますけど
それはただの遊びであって
心の中には全然ないんです
そういうことは 何か批判してやったらすぐそれにいかしちゃう
ですから このそういう生き方っていうのは中道的な生き方なんです
そういう生き方になっちゃうと
ものすごい人間には立派な生き方になっちゃうんだけど
誰とも戦わない 例えば会社で自分がもう 1ヶ月間徹夜して研究して研究してレポート書いたんだと
そこで会議室でまあ何もしないで
みんな集めてなんかちょっとちょっと何とか横に読んだだけで
君 ここら辺はもうどうかな
ここはちょっと違うでしょ
ここは間違ってるでしょとか
さんざん批判するでしょうかもしれません
そうすると  1ヶ月間徹夜して書いた人はものすごい気持ち悪くなったりとか
自信が失ったりとか あるいはこの人はとにかく私の足を引っ張ろうとしてるんではないかとかね
あるいは腹が立ったりとかね
私は一人で苦労していたのに
この人々は全然苦労もしないで
偉そうに批判してゴミ箱に捨ててるんではないかと
私のレポートはとかね
というここがいくらでもあるでしょ
会社の中で そういうのは消えちゃうんです
何のことなく 一応レポートは書きましたけど
いかがでしょうかと そこであっちこっちから批判が出ると
あ そうですか そうですか
それでちょっとメモしてるけど
あ そうですか はいはい
全くクールな心で 気づいた自分が気づいた
気づかなかったところを向こうが言ったら
あ なるほど それは私は気づかなかったと
そうすると素晴らしい環境でしょ
雰囲気が 批判する人もすごい気持ちいいんです
自分の意見は通りましたと
批判される側も あ みんな真面目に言ってくれるんだと
気持ちいいんです 私も批判されちゃったら
僕はものすごく気持ちいいんですけど
それに反応する みんなによく平気でいろんなこと言いますねとかね
それはただ遊んでるだけで
別に腹が立っていくいうわけじゃないんで
みんな誤解するみたいんだけどね
批判すると僕はそれなりにいろいろ反応するんです
それは遊んでるだけで
批判はちゃんと聞いてるんです
ちゃんと聞いてものすごい速さでそれを直しちゃうんです
頭の中で すぐその場で直して新しいプログラム作る
頭の中で 2度と同じ間違いは結構起こさないようにする
だからといって 死ぬまで僕は不完全なんです
この話は 僕はずっとやっても不完全なんです
それはどうしようもないんです
できない 言葉 不完全であるならば
言葉は偏見でしょうに
我々の知識は偏見でしょうに
言葉によって私は喋っていることも偏見でしょうに
もう偏見だらけだから完全になるわけないんですね
じゃあ例を言いましょう
皆様に私はこのガラスを手で取って見せます
皆様方はこのガラスを見たと思ってるでしょ
そこで皆様方 同じガラスを見ましたと
でも違うんです 皆様方
そのその場所によって違う側面を見ているんです
ガラスそのものを見ているわけじゃないんです
ですから 各方々が見ていて
あ 見たという認識が偏見なんです
私はこちらから見ていて
すごい近い距離で見ていて
皆様がそのその距離で見ていて
光の当て方 反射し方はそれぞれ違うんであって
それだけじゃない 目の視力もそれぞれ違うでしょ
それだけじゃない ガラスと判断するときは
頭の中の過去の記憶あるでしょ？その過去の記憶と比べて判断するんです
ものすごい高価なガラス
一つ1万 1万  2万円のガラスも皆様の家にあると思いますけど
ご家庭に そういうガラスで水を飲んでる人から見れば
ガラスはガラスですよというふうに感じるでしょうね
そこら辺に売ってる 100円のガラスで水を飲んでる方だったら
また違う感じがするちゃうでしょ
ですから する感じも自分の我々の今
過去の記録によっても左右される
ですから 私はガラスを見たということは
どういうことかというと
それぞれ方々 自分の偏見で認識したということで
ガラスを見たということにならないんです
ですから 皆様に私は言うならば
じゃあ皆様方同じガラス見たでしょ
ですから そのガラスについて語ってくださいと言ったら
語れるならばみんな違う違うことを言うかもしれません
もし何人いらっしゃるかわかりませんだけど
15人の方々は 15人
5種類の意見を述べるんです
それで私は聞きたい だからお互いに意見は違うんだから喧嘩するべきかと
喧嘩して済みますかね
決して済みません 腹が立って済みますかね
済みないです ただ単に 15種類の意見があるだけ
それどっちでも間違ってはないし
完璧でもないし そのガラスだって上から見たら一つ
下から見たらまた横から見たらまた回してみるとまた違うとか
いろいろ見方なんですね
遠くから見ると 近く見ると
顕微鏡で見ると いろんなものを見えちゃう
すべての我々の生きる世界はそういう世界なんです
ですから 私は言いたいのは
どんな意見にも執着する必要ない
自分の意見に自分考えていることに仏教についても執着すると腹が立っちゃうんです
私はこのいろいろ意見批判した意見
いろいろあるんですよ
世の中で間違ってる意見もありますよ
ちゃんと間違ってる意見も
批判しちゃったら 皆様方もうどうも機嫌が悪くなっちゃうんですね
で 機嫌が悪くなって私にいろいろ反論するんですね
で そこら辺で問題はどういうことかというと
自分の意見は自分だと正しいんだとどこかで思って捕まってるんですね
だから機嫌が悪くなって怒ったりはする
腹が立ったりする 何も意見持たないで人の話聞くと
ずっとその通りにわかるんです
僕は勉強する時で 昔からもうやった悪いやり方なんですけど
もう勉強するのは嫌いで
後でノート書いて暗記するのはもう嫌いで
その時間は遊びたいんですね
暇があれば遊ぶと 強引に勉強させちゃうと勉強すると
捕まって勉強させなかったらしない
もう大学でもみんな学生たちが一生懸命徹夜して勉強するんですね
僕はかぶれて寝たがっちゃうんで
そこは友達でしたから
みんな引っ張ってこっち来いとぶん殴られたりして
いろいろこといじめ，まあお坊さん同士だからね
こういうことないんだけど
もう一緒に勉強しろよと
そしたらみんな友達の仲間は楽しいんだから
私も徹夜してまあやってるんだけど
面白くないんですね で
僕はどんな工夫かというと
小さい時からも先生は何か教えるとそのその立場で聞くんです
自分の立場じゃなくて
自分が変身するんです
相手の立場に で 相手の立場に変身して聞いちゃうと
まあわかるんです その通りに理解したらそのまま覚えて覚えちゃうし
で すごい便利なんです
それからはもう理解しているんだから
で それでもう忘れないんです
別に工夫しなくても まあ例えば分かりやすく言えば
もうなんでしょうかね
例えばテレビで総論会あります
いろんな政治家が出てきて
そこでテレビの NHK の政治討論を聞いていると
皆様方は日本の方々だから
自分自分ももしかすると党があるかもしれません
ある場合は 自分の党の人が喋ると
その立場の自分になって話を聞いたりして
相手の方が言うと違う意見を聞いてるような感じで
違うんじゃないか おかしいことを言ってるんじゃないかと思うかもしれません
そして 私の言い方 やり方は違うんですね
自民党の方が喋ると 自分もその立場で聞く
じゃあ自民党と政権取ってる人としては
この問題はどうするべきかというと
なるほど それはその通り
例えば沖縄の問題に対しては
まあすごく曖昧で曖昧でああだこうだとか
僕は気持ちわかるんですね
自民党は政権取ってるし
アメリカとはもう仲良くしたいし
日本人の国民よりはアメリカの機嫌を取ることはものすごく大変大事だと思ってるし
ですから 沖縄の人々のこともわかってるし
だからといっていけ帰ってくださいということを言っちゃったら
自分の立場が危ないし
ですから 曖昧で曖昧でいろいろめちゃめちゃと
他の党の方が喋ると責任はないし
ですから 客観的に徹底的に喋れるんですね
日本にはそういう軍事軍隊は要りませんとか
何とかとか それで僕はまあそう考えれば日本には全然要りませんと
別に日本人が戦争するわけでもないし
誰かと喧嘩するわけでもないし
外国から来て日本を戦略するということは全く今のうちはほとんどないし
だからそんなまあいることは結局危ないんですね
軍隊があること自体危ないんだから
なぜならば 戦争あったら日本
いくら日本人反対したっても
アメリカ軍隊はね 日本を中心にして戦争するんだから巻き込まれちゃいますよ
ですから 今から考えると
やっぱりみんな帰った方が平和だなと
その立場でわかるんです
でも だからといって それ自民党わかってはいるんだけど
やっぱり実行できないとか
そういうふうにいろいろ人の立場でそれを聞いて理解する
だから自分別に立場取る必要はないし
そういう中道的なとこを持ってください
なんかまた難しい話になりましたけど
まあ例えば家庭の問題で
姑さんが お嫁さんがもう悪いという概念で喧嘩しちゃう
姑さんはお嫁さんが お嫁さんも姑さんが悪いと
どっちも悪いわけでもいいわけでもないんです
お嫁さんが姑さんの立場を理解するともう納得いくし
姑さんもお嫁さんの立場を理解すると納得いくんですよ
お嫁さんが全部自分で権力を取りたがっちゃう
旦那さんは自分のものにしたがって
それも夫婦だから当たり前のことで
そこ放っておけばいいんです
結婚してあげたいんだから勝手にしろと
でも お嫁さんが全然経験ないんだから
料理もできないし 味付けの味が悪いし
いろいろあるかもしれません
姑さんには気に入らない
どうせ違う家の人だから
もうなんだかんだ違うんだから気に入らない
気に入らないけど やっぱり違う家の人だから気に入らないのは当たり前でしょうと
そこら辺は理解してみましょうと言って
私は正しい立場で喋るんだから
この永遠のお嫁と姑さんの問題が出てくるんです
私は正しいということはないということを理解すると
問題は消える 会社の場合も同じ
上司の方々がすぐもう部下をバカにしちゃうんです
そんなにバカにすることはできないでしょうに
自分が正しかったんですかね
自分も同じ過ちをお互い犯して犯して経験を積み重ねてきただけで
自分もいまだに過ちを犯しているし
ですから それはそれで理解して
世の中にもすべての問題消えるんですよ
すべての問題 この中道的な立場を理解すると
ですから とにかくポイントは 2つ
私は決して正しく 決して完璧ではない
私の意見は決して完全に正しくないというポイントと
2番目は 相手の立場をその環境の中で理解しましょうと
その相手の環境の中で
条件の中で理解しましょうと
それ2つだけ それに加えて
またいろんなポイントは言えますけどね
相手理解することは決して自分が負けることではありません
我々は嫌がるのは負けたくないんですね
喧嘩になるのはそういうことでしょう
負けたくはないんです
夫婦喧嘩の場合 男は逃げるでしょ
あれは負けたくないんだからな
どうせ喧嘩しちゃったら負けちゃいますから
もう逃げろと 逃げてすむんですね
とにかく人間っていうのは負けたくないんだから
いろんな喧嘩っていうものが世の中で生まれるんです
ですから そんなものは勝ち負けの問題じゃありません
相手の言っていることはもうよく理解する
それは自分が負けたことじゃありません
それは自分が立派な人間であることなんです
理解できるんだから ですから
相手のことを理解することは
決して自分が負けることではありませんと
逆に自分が正しいと思って喧嘩して勝っても
自分が直せる機会を失っちゃうんです
私知ってること正しいんだ言って大きな声でしゃべったりして
もうひっそり起こしたりして
怒鳴ったりして相手を抑える抑えるでしょ
喧嘩では 今勝ったような気持ちになっちゃって
あれで勝ったじゃなくて負けてるんです
いろんな 僕は喧嘩っていうのは
この体の喧嘩 口喧嘩だけではなくて
ありとあらゆる人間のぶつかり合い
経済 政治 哲学 宗教 家庭の中
社会の中 すべてぶつかり合い
そこで勝ったぞと思ったりはしますけど
そこで負けてるんです
どこで負けてるんです
自分に負けてる 自分がもう直せませんから
ですから この強い自分の意見はとにかく押し押し押し付けちゃったら
自分を直す機会は失う
いわゆる自分がさらにいい人間になることはできなくなっちゃう
人間がダメにするいい言葉があるんです
私は知ってるんだと それでその人は愚か者になるんだとお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
私は知ってるんだと思ったら
それによって愚か者になるんだと
私は知らないと知る人が賢者になるんだと
それは釈迦様の言葉なんですね
ですから 我々はやっぱり毎日賢者になりたいんですね
毎日成長したいんですね
それだったら私は知らないということを覚えた方がやりやすい
知らないってことは 頭が全く悪いとは意味じゃないんです
いろんな知識はありますよ
あるんだけど それはその通りで
それは究極的な真理だということは別にないんだから
私もいっぱい仏教を勉強しましたから
頭の中では全部染み込んでいるんだけど
だからといって全部完璧に知ってるってこと
とんでもない話なんです
やっぱりずっとやっぱり知らないんだという立場でいた方が
どんどんどんどん自分の器が大きくなって
いろいろ知恵が入って大きくなっていくんですね
そういうことで 知らないということがすごく正直に心に言ってあげる
その 生きる というふうな
このお釈迦様はこの中道というすごい難しいことをね
それをもう悟らなきゃわからないもんだから
そこはそこまでは待たないで
いくらか世の中で我々実践してみると
すぐ瞬時に自分には素晴らしい平和な世界が現れてくる
どんなコンフランテーション
逆らう 戦う ぶつかり合うことは何一つもない
以スムーズで生きていられる社会がその場で生まれてくるんです
普通の人間は社会直そうとしてるんですよ
喧嘩 あの人と喧嘩するんだから
あの人の性格をちょっと直してくれませんかと
そうすると永遠に直してくれませんだから
自分の我がままだから
自分を直せばいいんです
それは一番早いんです
自分が平和を守ると 人の意見と戦わない
人の意見は聞いてあげると
聞いてあげるだけじゃなくて
真剣に聞いて真剣に理解すると
別に頭に脳細胞いっぱいあるんだから
なんだかんだ理解したって別に構いませんよ
何の危険もないんだから
そういうことで 片っ端から世の中のことは
まあ会う会う人のことはちゃんと理解しますと
自分の意見をぶっぶっぶっ殴って喧嘩にはしませんと
自分の意見を言う場合は
頼まれた場合は この問題については私はこう思ってますよと謙虚で言えばいいんです
相手側が違いますって言ったら
ああそうでございますかと
まあ私はそう思っているだけですよと
それは構いませんと それだけで問題は終わるんです
じゃあ時間は過ぎ去りましたので